hello my name is Lizzy Kaplan and I feel
confused about being Conan O'Brien's
friend okay yeah it sounded honest it
was uh your confusion let's talk about
your confusion first confused because I
was under the impression that we already
were kind of friends so I thought we
were too and then I checked the
paperwork no oh we never got to friend's
status right I saw that I just forged
like a cat paw print instead of
paperwork
well uh yes we should disclose that uh
we have been friendly for a number of
years and
um yeah very friendly I think and I have
dined uh in recently with you and your
just incredible husband yeah who um
enrages me with his talent and good
looks yes both those things yes and he
can tell too it feels pity for me yeah
yeah oh yeah but
um we also had a really good time we
hung out in England I was there to
interview Ricky Gervais and you were
living there at the time with Tom and
you guys joined up with me and we ended
up having
um Guinness uh in a real Pub in the
northern part of London I think yeah and
you ordered a scotch egg okay
yes and I thought what's a scotch egg
because you
I romanticize when people live in a
foreign country that's always something
I dream about so you come into the pub
you're nice enough to meet up with me
you guys you and Tom come in and you sit
down and then you just seem to be
uh so comfortable like you would become
British and you ordered a scotch egg
which I didn't even know what a scotch
egg do you know what it is yeah it's a
isn't an egg wrapped in sausage and then
fried that's correct oh yeah yeah I've
had a scotch quails egg before Oh dainty
I I knew to turn to Gourley for this
because if there's something
anything slightly uh give me English
would make it dangerous yeah
don't tell that you romanticized it
because you just called it like a real
Pub
yeah I know I know I know but I get very
uh I'm nerdy in a lot of ways but one of
my things when I was in when I'm walking
around in London I just keep thinking
I'm in London yeah yeah now I'm in a pub
in London Sam I'll have a Guinness I'm
drinking the Guinness in London I'm
wearing a Tweed cap I mean I'm I don't
know I'm so self-conscious I feel like
that all the time about everything and
only recently do I feel like I'm
shedding that
thing like that I'm not doing commentary
about the normal things that people just
seem to be doing around me without you
know thinking too hard about it right
right but we did drink a lot of Guinness
that day in the middle of the day I may
have had more than you guys yeah maybe
maybe Tom was just saying he's like you
guys you drink when you're together like
you and I yeah and I don't feel like I
drink that much but when I'm with you my
best friendly
Ben I also think I mean I could be wrong
but there's something about Guinness
that feels like it doesn't count like if
I had if someone was putting down scotch
or anything like that I'm not big into
spirits but if it's Guinness I don't
know what it is I don't feel like it
counts it's like a meal yeah it is if
someone put took a loaf of pumpernickel
bread and put it into a paper shredder
and then let it sit for a couple of
months yeah it's Bread soup it's Bread
soup and then you drink it yeah but we
had we had a very good time and I have
wanted you to be on the podcast
for a long time because and I say this
with uh just write out you're one of my
favorite people you really are you you
say that to everybody that walks up
25 of the people but I do feel their
sincerity in your voice this time so I'd
put that in the top five percent come on
I'm serious yeah yeah well I think uh
yeah you're nonsense
no I'm kidding I'm no he really
sincerely means it yeah
I'm always and and the other person my
wife knows it my wife knows that I have
Lizzie Kaplan fever and she's like yeah
I get it I totally get it just the fact
that you two drink together he won't
drink with us God no no no no I take a
lot of pills when I'm around you but I
don't drink but that's just for your hip
you can take a pill for your hand you
could take a pill for anything